l'urgence est la panique dans la
capitale ukrainienne le centre de kiev a
été touchée jeudi soir par plusieurs
mais c'est le russe après deux semaines
d'accalmie l' attaque qui a fait au
moins une dizaine de blessés est
survenue en pleine visite du secrétaire
général de l'onu
je ne pense pas que le fait que le
secrétaire général soit dans la capitale
ukrainienne ou non soit important ce qui
compte c'est qu'une attaque est eu lieu
et cela m'a choqué car kiev est une
ville sacrée pour les ukrainiens comme
pour les russes le président ukrainien a
immédiatement fustigé cette attaque
cela en dit long sur la véritable
attitude de la russie envers les
institutions mondiales sur les efforts
de dirigeants russes humiliés l'onu et
tout ce que l'organisation représente
plus tôt dans la journée le secrétaire
général de l'onu a rencontré volodymyr
zelensky dans la foulée de sa visite à
moscou au menu des discussions
le défi humanitaire
antonio guterres s a réaffirmé son
soutien au peuple ukrainien tout en
dénonçant les manquements de son
organisation permettez-moi d'être très
clair le conseil de sécurité a échoué à
mettre tout en oeuvre pour empêcher
mettre fin à cette guerre et cela est
source de grande déception frustration
et colère
dans la matinée il s'était rendu dans
plusieurs villes de la périphérie de
kiev des lieux de multiples exactions
présumées
comme ici à bord odienne cas
rien ne justifiera jamais cette guerre
c'est inacceptable au 21ème siècle
j'imagine ma famille dans une de ces
maisons complètement détruite
je vois mes petites-filles s'enfuir en
panique abandonnant derrière elle tous
ces morts
direction ensuite bocsa devenue le
symbole de la brutalité et des violences
russe le patron de l'onu appelle la
russie à coopérer avec la cour pénale
internationale qui a ouvert une enquête
pour de possibles crimes de guerre comme
dans cette ville mais la russie continue
de nier tout crime